[Music]
on this monday night offline a social
media giant crashes the ripple effects
of the facebook instagram and whatsapp
outage the day after a whistleblower
tells all facebook over and over again
has shown it uses profit over safety can
the world function without facebook
sisters in spirit honoring missing and
murdered indigenous women and girls
we're letting the families know that
they're not alone the race to contain an
oil spill off california the company's
prior violations
and at age 90 he's actually making the
trek come on
william shatner's upcoming flight to the
edge of space
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
the world got a big reminder today about
how reliant we are on social media
companies facebook and its other
platforms including instagram and
whatsapp were out of service for about
six hours today affecting potentially
billions of users facebook's internal
systems used by employees also went down
they're coming back online now the
company has not said what caused it last
night the cbs news program 60 minutes
aired an interview with a whistleblower
who says facebook puts profits ahead of
safety
facebook has realized that
if they change the algorithm to be safer
people will spend less time on the site
they'll click on less ads they'll make
less money
francis hogan worked on facebook's civic
integrity team for two years before she
left in may she's set to testify before
congress tomorrow about facebook's
impact especially on young users the
impact of this outage is hard to
overstate it affected governments
businesses and individuals around the
world
mike armstrong has our top story tonight
whatever happened happened just before
noon eastern facebook and what it calls
its family of apps went down in their
place an error message the sort of thing
you see when you're not connected to the
internet except it appears it's facebook
itself and its apps things like
instagram whatsapp and messenger that
are the ones not connected total outage
no signs of life
for
facebook any facebook services globally
this is huge
facebook had to take to twitter to
explain tweeting that it was working to
get things back to normal as quickly as
possible the issue appears to be a
problem with the company's information
on the internet's domain name system dns
users logging on can't reach the site
because its dns information isn't there
it's like losing access to a phone
number the likely cause experts say an
error in a new security configuration
all the information that's out there
appears that facebook was making some
sort of change and that in the process
of making that change they accidentally
disabled this and locked themselves out
there are reports one of the reasons the
outage dragged on so long is because so
many facebook employees are working from
home when they got locked out they
couldn't fix the problem in fact their
reports employees then had difficulties
even getting into the company's offices
physically it's alleged that when they
got there none of them could get into
the building because their
badges and id system is all tied into
that same network that's not working now
there is still a chance a hacker went
after the company that was a possibility
a lot of people jumped to when it went
down facebook has been swirling in
criticism in recent weeks and took a big
hit sunday night on 60 minutes the
program interviewed a whistleblower who
says facebook is tearing societies apart
by putting profits ahead of the public
good
when we live in an information
environment that is full of angry
hateful polarizing content it erodes our
civic trust
it erodes our faith in each other that
whistleblower is set to testify to u.s
lawmakers tuesday but experts say that
the outage came the very next day after
her revelations is likely just a
coincidence
mike armstrong global news
facebook stock took a big hit today
recording its worst day of the year on
the markets it closed at just over 326
dollars a share that's down nearly five
percent
in alberta help is on its way to assist
overwhelmed health care workers medical
staff from the military the canadian red
cross and from newfoundland and labrador
are expected to arrive this week to help
in hospitals across the province there
are 298 people in alberta's icus now the
vast majority critically ill with
covid19 icu capacity is at 80 percent
but that includes the extra beds added
if there was no surge capacity alberta
icus would be at 172
capacity those patients of course are
not just numbers even after all the
world has endured from covid many never
expected the virus would make them so
sick heather urix west reports
this is my first day
in the hospital
always coping it has been almost a month
since jolene orr made this video the 24
year old is from slave lake in northern
alberta and for the last 24 days she's
been on a ventilator in an edmonton icu
it's hard to see my sister like this
because
i'm so used to her talking to me and
laughing with me and now it's just i
hear the ventilator just going and going
and going that's all i hear shakira says
both she and her big sister were
hesitant about the covet vaccine at
first but they eventually decided it was
the right thing to do
shakira was vaccinated in early august
jaleen had an appointment near the end
of the month
she got sick just two days before she
has or had a blood clot in her lung so
it's it's severe damage in her right now
and
the doctor said that
it would most likely take a miracle for
her to recover
icus across alberta are now filled with
patients like jalene with lower vaccine
coverage areas of central and northern
alberta have been particularly hard hit
our icu has been just overwhelmed for
weeks now right running way beyond
maximum capacity
and there's a lot of a lot of challenges
that go along with that it's why last
month the province asked ottawa for help
in addition to a small team of critical
care nurses from the canadian armed
forces medical staff from the canadian
red cross and the province of
newfoundland are expected to arrive
later this week i think the
help
if it can
alleviate or give some reprieve to some
of our frontline teams i think that that
i think people would be are grateful for
that
i worry
it won't be enough
doctors groups have been calling on the
province to implement more health
restrictions including a lockdown to
bring covet infection numbers down
scheduled surgeries have now been
canceled across the province for several
weeks
already there are thousands of surgeries
to catch up on shakira or just hopes her
sister will survive a lot of people love
her and i know
that a lot of people are praying for her
heather urex west global news calgary
more and more provinces are requiring
proof of vaccination to enter public
places that will help reduce the number
of people who get infected but the delta
variant is still surging in some parts
of this country and as eric sorensen
reports holidays such as thanksgiving
could increase it again
nova scotia is the latest province to
require proof of full vaccination to
access non-essential locations like gyms
theaters and restaurants we were super
busy we had a line up out the door and
all of our guests all had their id and
their covet proof at this gym they hope
proof of vaccination will keep covid
cases down and keep their doors open
whatever's going to keep us safe during
this time and gives us a final a gradual
transition back to some sense of
normalcy is something that we're looking
forward to all provinces now have or
will soon have a type of vaccine
passport while two-thirds of canadians
got their first doses last spring
government mandates may have spurred a
recent uptake in july 1.2 million
canadians got their first dose the
number dropped to below 1 million in
august but as vaccine requirements
increased more than 1.3 million got
their first doses in september
requirements have been put into place by
lots of different jurisdictions
employers and so forth that directly
influences kind of where we're seeing
things in terms of uptake new brunswick
is now fighting its biggest surge in
covid cases highlighting regional
differences british columbia has just
made masks mandatory in schools for all
children even as young as kindergarten
while the national picture suggests the
fourth wave is leveling off it depends
on your province the three westernmost
provinces bc alberta and saskatchewan
have all seen sharp recent spikes in
covid cases while the two biggest
provinces ontario and quebec have kept
the fourth wave relatively in check in
atlanta canada a big surge in new
brunswick where cases have spiked to
more than double the highest rate that
province has seen in the pandemic the
delta variant is proving to be more
opportunistic finding clusters of people
who are not fully vaccinated we
certainly know that it's far more
contagious than the alpha variant was
which was again what drove our third
wave being more contagious could make
thanksgiving a risk even with widespread
vaccinations because children are still
not vaccinated the best way to keep
children safe is to ensure that the
adults around them are vaccinated and we
need to be really careful about that to
ensure that you know we're not doing
things that will later result in
increased outbreaks in school settings
advice for this thanksgiving smaller
gatherings are better than larger ones
and keep the windows open for better
ventilation eric sorensen global news
toronto
health canada is now reviewing an
experimental anti-viral drug that could
cut hospitalizations and deaths from
covid19 by as much as half it is not
approved yet and it needs more review
jamie morocco explains what we know and
don't know about the antiviral pill
unvaccinated patients continue to fill
up canadian hospitals leaving doctors
and nurses at their breaking point we're
just as coveted exhausted as everybody
else
and things need to change
for a system under stress experts are
hopeful this little pill mauna piravir
could offer some alleviation currently
all health canada approved cova
treatments require a medical
professional to be administered similar
to tamiflu malnou piravir would be taken
at home orally to help dampen the
effects of the illness oral therapy is
always going to be easier to give but i
think the important component is that
it's this is not a cure for covet in
clinical trials drug maker merck says
the twice a day antiviral reduced
hospitalizations and deaths in covid
patients by 50 percent matthias gauter
and his team at the university of
alberta tested the efficacy of the drug
before merck's results were even
released the drug doesn't really inhibit
the virus but it causes the virus to
make too many mistakes
forcing it to make a sloppy copy that is
no longer infectious goty says it's
important to get the drug to patients
soon after diagnosis monoperovir can be
taken much earlier before the virus has
caused already so much damage that
antivirals don't work anymore as early
as five days after infection according
to merck's trials it provides another
way that we can effectively treat people
and reduce the risk of hospitalization
and death which is incredibly important
obviously but it doesn't mean that those
who haven't been vaccinated should sit
back now and say i don't need to worry
with no shortage of shots in canada that
experts say remains the first and best
line of defense
jamie morocco global news toronto
vigils across the country today are
honoring the lives of missing and
murdered indigenous women girls and
two-spirit people it is known as sisters
in spirit day as raquel fletcher reports
many indigenous women say they do feel
more supported now and are taking back
their power and a warning some of the
details in her story are disturbing
red dresses blowing in the wind at this
vigil in chelsea quebec are a sad
reminder of canada's missing and
murdered indigenous women
vigils around the country monday are
honoring these women's lives we're
letting the families know that they're
not alone
in alberta natawaki english organized a
march in honor of her daughters one of
them brutally murdered in 2015. joey's
body was dismembered and
was spread around calgary alberta
crescent high parks in the landfills to
this day joey's limbs still sit in the
landfills
and only her torso and head came home
for the last four years english has
walked this nearly 200 kilometer stretch
of highway from her first nation to this
vigil in calgary every year it grows
exponentially
fighting for their cause since 2005 the
indigenous women behind sisters in
spirit hope public interest and
reconciliation and observation of last
week's truth and reconciliation holiday
will mean more visibility and more
support for the calls to action from the
inquiry into missing and murdered
indigenous women crown indigenous
relations minister carolyn bennett
saying in a statement we offer support
to the families and communities who bear
the grief of their loss and to the
survivors whose lives have been forever
changed prime minister justin trudeau
was notably absent last thursday caught
vacationing in tofino instead of
participating in any of the truth and
reconciliation day events he won't be
attending any of the vigils monday
either his office saying that he will
instead light a candle in his window as
recommended by the native women's
association of canada whether he shows
up to these or not we have the support
of canada we have support of other
canadians that are allies to us we're
the daring ones to take that step ahead
and do something about it right women
the women power raquel fletcher global
news ottawa
the consequences of an oil spill off
california coming up the cleanup
underway and the company's track record
[Music]
work is underway to contain and mop up a
huge oil spill off the coast of southern
california more than 480 000 liters of
heavy crude leaked from an underwater
pipeline owned by amplify energy the
slick spans about 33 square kilometers
between huntington beach and newport
beach it's one of the largest spills in
california's history local officials
call it an environmental catastrophe and
say the oil has reached sensitive
wetlands
we do have sightings of additional oiled
gulls and other shorebirds that are
flighted so very difficult to catch but
we're pursuing other alternative capture
strategies such as using mist nets and
other techniques to be able to catch
those animals very quickly
the company says the pipeline has been
shut down investigators are narrowing in
on the source of the leak and are
considering a ship's anchor as a
possible cause amplify energy emerged
from bankruptcy four years ago and has a
long record of federal non-compliance
incidents and violations
the pandora papers ahead the documents
exposing how the uber rich hide their
wealth
there is a widely held view that the
ultra-rich are rigging the system well
the latest leaked documents called the
pandora papers expose how many rich
people use offshore accounts and complex
webs of financial engineering much of it
is legal some of it is not the end
result is the same many of the richest
people in the world avoid paying tax and
on the list are kings presidents and
sports stars plus more than 500
canadians and gabiola reports
from pop star shakira to russian
president vladimir putin the king of
jordan and former british prime minister
tony blair the pandora papers shed light
on how the rich and famous have used
offshore accounts over the last quarter
century providing privacy and tax
avoidance tools so hidden trillions in
assets can be tucked away often for
shady purposes the pandora papers probed
nearly 12 million files including emails
and bank statements 330 current and
former politicians are mentioned the
expose the work of 600 journalists from
117 countries to be clear it's not
illegal to have an offshore bank account
or to set up a company in another
country as long as it's disclosed and
the appropriate taxes are paid the
problem with tax havens though is that
they're a go-to for money launderers
criminals and tax evaders so our tax
system makes it just a bit too easy to
pay very little tax when you're holding
assets abroad and investing abroad more
than 500 canadian citizens or residents
are mentioned in the papers many aren't
household names but some are high
profile like olympic figure skater elvis
stoico who moved six and a half million
in assets to an offshore trust in 2007.
or formula one champion jacques
villeneuve who has lived in quebec shown
to have set up companies in zero tax
jurisdictions for his racing and
endorsement incomes in a statement to
global news the canada revenue agency
reiterates its commitment to protecting
the integrity of the canadian tax system
by combating international tax evasion
and aggressive tax avoidance
domestically and internationally
the liberal platform pledged to increase
cra resources by up to a billion
annually but the opposition says there
hasn't been a single conviction for tax
evasion in the six years that trudeau
has been in office we've had
historically low enforcement
over money laundering and white-collar
crime in canada
tax experts say that since a similar
investigation the panama papers were
released five years ago some rules
globally and in canada have changed to
catch tax avoiders but with the right
lawyers and accountants companies and
individuals are still able to play hide
and seek with their wealth ann gaviola
global news toronto
next look who's heading to the final
frontier
what do a chili pepper and a hug have in
common a nobel prize two american
scientists share this year's nobel prize
for physiology or medicine for their
work on sensing touch and temperature
david julius and arden patapudian
discovered how our bodies convert
physical sensations into electrical
messages in the nervous system such as
the burning we feel when we eat a chili
pepper or the comforting warmth of a hug
from a loved one heat cold and touch are
crucial to our own survival and how our
bodies do it has been a mystery the
findings could lead to new ways of
treating pain
canadian actor william shatner is going
to the edge of space for real at age 90
shatner who's best known as captain
james t kirk is getting a seat on the
blue origin rocket the space travel
company billionaire jeff bezos created
shatner is more famous than many actual
astronauts for his voyages on the
starship enterprise and next week
fiction meets reality mike drolet
explains
mr spock
it's him it's the captain william
shatner used to hate all the attention
that came with being captain kirk
it took him decades of cheesy sets and
overacting
before he finally accepted the impact he
made on space exploration today one of
the most visited artifacts at the
national air and space museum in
washington which has you know apollo 11
and
john glenn space capsule and all that
is the is the model of the enterprise
that they used uh during the star trek
series
so shatner became synonymous with space
without ever having gone
well next week that's gonna change on
twitter he announced it's true i'm gonna
be a rocket man command engine start two
one
and not only that at 90 years old he'll
become the oldest person to go to space
in history taking the title from 82 year
old wally funk who flew on blue origin's
new shepard spacecraft in july already
standing by it took over 50 years for
kirk to go where no actor has gone
before
but alas he won't be the first actor
because the russians beat him to it in a
move that harkens back to the space race
of the 1950s and 60s russia is now
sending up a film crew tomorrow to shoot
the first movie in space
even so they won't get anywhere near the
attention because of william james t
kirk shatner soon to be rocket man
burning out his fuse out here hello mike
global news toronto
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is the big muddy badlands in
southern saskatchewan thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow take care of yourselves bye-bye
you